Olá, boa noite.
O tema da minha conversa é,
dentro deste espírito "What if...?"
aquilo que me foi proposto foi:
"E se eu me transformar
numa personagem de banda desenhada?"
Portanto, a primeira coisa
que eu vos quero mostrar
foi uma coisa que aconteceu
— não estava à espera
mas dei por mim, de repente,
eu era uma banda desenhada
e o que vocês vão ver ali
sou eu em boneco.
Este boneco foi criado
e depois, eu não satisfeito,
arrastei a minha família
para dentro deste espírito
da banda desenhada.
Originalmente, a minha ideia
era bastante mais simples.
Só queria ter uma página
de humor no Facebook.
Mas, como tenho quatro filhos,
e os miúdos têm uma grande facilidade
de dizer disparates
e de criar material cómico
que facilmente pode ser utilizado,
e como o pai também
já é dado ao disparate, pensei:
"Eu e os meus quatro co-argumentistas,
isto só pode correr bem".
Então, vamos fazer
uma página de humor, os cinco.
Depois, pensei:
Como é que a gente pode fazer isto?
Olha, podemos fazer em banda desenhada,
uma coisa fantástica para um tipo
que não sabe desenhar.
que é o meu caso.
Eu gosto de arranjar lenha
para me queimar.
Pedi a uma amiga
que, por acaso, não conheço
— somos amigos do Facebook,
há três anos —
ela é daqui do Porto,
mas não nos conhecemos.
Eu sei que ela é ilustradora,
perguntei se ela sabia desenhar,
disse que sim,
eu dei-lhe as fotografias,
ela devolveu-mas.
Vocês podem ver pelo desenho,
o desenho está delicioso
Eu fiquei apaixonado pelo meu boneco.
Mandei-lhe as fotografias dos meus filhos,
ela devolveu-me as fotografias
e, de repente, transformámo-nos todos
em personagens de BD.
Só que eu tenho este drama
de não saber desenhar.
Portanto, de cada vez que tenho
uma história para contar,
uma conversa à mesa do jantar,
no supermercado, onde quer que seja,
eu não posso estar a criar um cenário
para cada conversa.
Vocês sabem que os "designers"
para cumprirem prazos...
É impossível, não vale a pena
sequer pedir-lhes.
Portanto, aquilo que eu pedi
à minha ilustradora foi:
"Faz-me um cenário fechado
"em que depois — porque eu domino
o programa de ilustração —
"possa mexer nas bocas, nas caras,
faço os textos, faço as tirinhas
"e depois faço a página com autonomia".
Como sou eu que levo
os miúdos à escola, de manhã,
e nalguns dias, também sou eu
que os vou buscar,
lembrei-me de criar
o cenário da carrinha,
porque na carrinha também há
muitas conversas com os miúdos,
e eles estão com os cintos de segurança
não podem fugir, o que é bom, também.
E então, lembrámo-nos de criar
uma carrinha virtual.
Como gosto de carros antigos,
lembrei-me de criar a "pão de forma".
Este foi o cenário que foi criado
para a página do Facebook.
Já agora, apresento
o resto das personagens.
Elas estão aqui, de viva voz.
Este sou eu, sou o Fernando,
sou o pai
Aquela é a Rita, é a minha filha
mais velha, tem 10 anos.
A que apareceu agora foi a Rosa,
que é gémea da Rita,
mas não é a mais velha,
é dois minutos mais nova.
são dois minutos
que, na hierarquia lá de casa,
fazem alguma diferença.
O Zé tem seis anos
e a Joana, que tem quatro anos.
Portanto, estas são as cinco estrelas
que aparecem, de forma sistemática,
na nossa carrinha.
Quem aparece, de vez em quando,
é a mãe das crianças,
a Maria João, que é a minha mulher.
Mas, como é uma página de humor minha,
a minha mulher aparece muito raramente.
Somos nós as estrelas da companhia.
Eu também fiz questão,
tem que haver algum local
dentro da nossa família
em que seja eu a mandar.
(Risos)
(Aplausos)
Um homem que precisa de alguma autoestima
e de um sítio onde mandar, e é ali.
E há uma nova personagem.
Na Páscoa, fomos buscar a Dona Inês,
uma rafeira que fomos buscar a um canil
onde estava abandonada.
As miúdas estavam a pedir há muito tempo,
e elas também já tinham idade
para começar a tomar conta e a passear
então, adotámos a Dona Inês.
Criámos esta página.
Este para mim foi um fator crítico,
foi uma coisa que eu sempre quis fazer.
Hoje em dia, no Facebook
há muitos medos em relação aos miúdos,
as pessoas têm alguns receios,
e eu acho que isso é legítimo,
mas também queria fazer isto
com alguma ingenuidade
e, assim, quis assumir
as nossas caras e os nomes.
Se vocês olharem para a nossas caras,
são as nossas ilustrações
e eu uso os nossos nomes.
Podia ter criado
umas personagens fictícias,
um avatar, um pseudónimo qualquer,
mas eu queria que fôssemos mesmo nós.
Eu acho que isso também foi uma coisa
que fez com que a página crescesse.
As pessoas, que veem e comentam,
sabem que nós somos reais.
que existimos,
não somos personagens de ficção.
As pessoas identificam-se
facilmente com aquilo.
Aconteceu-nos uma coisa maravilhosa:
um mês depois de a página estar no ar,
eu recebi um convite da Bertrand
para passar a página a livro.
Eu tive que lhes explicar
que a página tinha só um mês,
não tinha material para passar a livro,
e eles tinham que refrear o entusiasmo.
Estivemos um ano a tornar a página
mais estruturada,
a aumentar a base de seguidores
e tudo o mais,
até que pudesse aparecer o livro.
Passado um ano e picos,
apareceu o livro.
O livro tem um prefácio do Nuno Markl.
É uma coisa que eu fiz questão e
tem a ver com a história do "What if...?"
e também com a questão da ingenuidade.
Gosto do Nuno Markl e quis
que fosse ele a fazer o prefácio,
mas tinha um problema,
não o conheço de lado nenhum,
nem tenho nenhum amigo que o conheça,
não podia ir por portas travessas.
Mas fui à página dele,
tinha lá um endereço de "email"
e eu mandei para lá um "email"
muito ingenuamente.
Depois, fomos trocando "emails",
ele aceitou fazer o prefácio
e correu muito bem.
Mas eu não quero transformar isto
numa história sobre mim ou sobre nós.
A questão do livro é que é importante
e vai chegar onde eu quero chegar.
Ajudem-me a fazer a ponte
para onde eu quero chegar,
que é: os formatos.
A questão da tecnologia é sempre
uma questão muito querida das TEDTalks.
Os formatos são compatíveis.
Quando temos uma ideia
e queremos implementá-la,
não precisamos de estar
excessivamente preocupados
com se esta nossa ideia é o último grito,
em termos tecnológicos,
não temos de ser cientistas da NASA
para ter uma ideia que triunfe.
Não é necessário.
Há coisas muito antigas
que já foram inventadas.
Às vezes, é no reinventar da roda
que está o sucesso das nossas ideias.
Este projeto que começou no Facebook,
está numa plataforma que tem
meia dúzia de anos
e, de repente, transformou-se num livro,
uma coisa inventada pelo Sr. Gutenberg
não sei se há 400 se há 500 anos.
Portanto, isto mostra como é possível
os formatos conviverem pacificamente.
Também a questão do avanço tecnológico
— e voltamos à questão do "What if...?" —
para mim, é "e se..."
as coisas fossem compatíveis?
Porque nós, quando falamos do progresso,
falamos sempre de forma
um bocado conflituosa.
Há sempre aquela ideia revolucionária
que o progresso se faz
pelo conflito entre partes
com sangue, com revoluções e tudo o mais.
E até em termos tecnológicos,
quem nos vende tecnologia,
para nos vender tecnologia
tem que nos criar a ideia
de que aquilo que estava
para trás está obsoleto.
que já não podemos usar.
E não é verdade.
Lembro-me de ser miúdo
e haver uma canção
— que, pelo menos,
o Álvaro Costa se lembra —
que foi viral, na altura
— o termo viral ainda não existia.
A canção era muito conhecida
e chamava-se
"Video killed the radio star".
Lembram-se disso?
A canção nem sequer fazia uma previsão:
"Video might kill the radio star"
Aquilo afirmava: o vídeo
matou a estrela da rádio.
Isto foi nos anos 80.
Se eu perguntar, tenho a certeza
que todos ouviram a rádio hoje
nem que seja um bocadinho,
ao virem para aqui.
e, se calhar, ninguém viu nada
em formato de vídeo.
Isso dá-vos uma ideia de como os arautos
das novas plataformas,
das novas tecnologias
tendem a estar errados.
De facto, as plataformas
conseguem conviver.
O vídeo ia matar a rádio...
a televisão ia matar a rádio...
o vídeo ia matar a televisão...
porque, com as cassetes VHS,
podiam ver o vídeo quando queriam,
já não precisavam de ver televisão.
Depois, entra em cena a Internet
e ia ser uma chacina.
A "net" ia matar a rádio,
ia matar os jornais
a "net" ia matar a televisão,
a "net" ia matar tudo.
Ia haver sangue por todos os lados.
Era o que nos vendiam.
Todas as plataformas
que nós conhecemos iam desaparecer
porque nós tínhamos tudo no ecrã
à distância de um "Enter".
E não aconteceu nada disso.
O engraçado, é que
não aconteceu nada disso.
A televisão teve que se reinventar,
evidentemente.
A televisão foi para o cabo,
criou canais específicos,
canais só de filmes, só de séries,
as pessoas podem ver televisão
através da "net".
No fundo, a televisão usou a "net"
também para se expandir.
Eles não entraram em conflito.
Tiveram que se ajustar
e trabalham em conjunto.
O mesmo se passa com a rádio.
A Fernanda, que esteve aqui,
pode ouvir o Álvaro Costa em Estocolmo,
nos "podcasts" da Antena 3,
ou pode ouvi-lo de manhã,
enquanto o Álvaro está a dormir,
ela está acordada em Estocolmo,
a ouvir o Álvaro Costa, e é fantástico!
A minha rádio favorita
é uma rádio local de Lisboa.
Eu vivo em Lisboa e trabalho em Sintra.
A rádio que oiço em casa
não consigo ouvir no trabalho, a Radar.
Mas ouço-a no computador
e vocês aqui no Porto
também a podem ouvir
e não tem problema nenhum.
A rádio usou a Internet para se expandir
e foi sempre assim que aconteceu.
Os jornais estão cheios de problemas,
todos sabemos.
Mas se vocês forem a uma banca de jornais
os jornais estão lá à venda.
Têm que se reinventar,
têm que reduzir as equipas,
essas coisas todas,
têm que se estruturar.
Mas os jornais continuam a existir.
A questão é: Uma ideia.
Nós nunca sabemos
qual é a ideia que vai triunfar.
Nunca sabemos.
E a ideia que temos,
que nos querem convencer
de que não é viável,
pode perfeitamente vir a ser viável.
pode vir a ser viável.
Vou colocar aqui uma imagem
a propósito de algo se tornar viral.
Aviso antecipadamente que esta imagem
é um bocado chocante,
porque vou trazer-vos à memória
algo de que vocês não se querem lembrar,
mas ainda assim...
(Risos)
Bom, vocês lembram-se desta praga?
Isto foi a coisa mais viral
que aconteceu no mundo.
Eu não sei se vocês têm ideia
do que este senhor
mostrou-nos, a mim e a vocês,
que o contador de "views" do Youtube
tinha um limite, mas ninguém sabia.
Eu pensava que era
um milhão, dois milhões, três milhões...
até ao infinito.
Não era.
Houve um dia em que o Youtube "crashou".
Estava tanta gente a ver este vídeo
que aquilo foi abaixo.
Este homem teve 2,5 mil milhões
de visualizações no Youtube!
É quase metade da população toda da Terra.
E vocês olham para aquilo
— eu estou a ver aqui a imagem —
O homem tem cara de parvo...
(Risos)
... veste de forma muito ridícula,
faz umas coreografias
que dá vontade de o internar...
(Risos)
... fala coreano que é uma língua
que 99,5% da população do mundo não fala,
mas isto tornou-se
na coisa mais viral do mundo!
Isto é tão inesperado!
Quem é que previu isto?
Algum de vocês previu?
Alguém previu que este marmanjo
ia tomar conta das nossas vidas
nem que fosse por uma fração de segundo?
Não sei, não sei qual é que foi a razão.
mas a verdade é que isto aconteceu.
Saindo da escala planetária,
e voltando para a escala de Portugal.
Eu até mudei de camisola
para apelar um bocadinho
aos cinco/seis-zero da produção nacional.
Há fenómenos em Portugal,
quer nós gostemos deles ou não.
Há fenómenos que se tornam virais.
Por exemplo, há bocado eu estava
a falar dos discos.
Dizia-se também que,
com a entrada da "net",
com o MP3, os "downloads", o SIM,
isso ia limitar muito a venda dos discos.
Sabemos que a música está em crise,
as vendas de discos.
Mas a Adele há coisa de uma semana
bateu o recorde de vendas
dum disco, numa semana,
e pulverizou o recorde que existia.
Se vocês pensarem,
mesmo em termos dos discos,
uma coisa que eu acho engraçada,
o CD nem sequer chegou a matar o vinil,
Houve uma altura
em que o vinil decaiu,
só encontrávamos o vinil
em lojas muito específicas
muito "underground",
onde os DJs iam comprar,
mas agora numa FNAC,
a secção de vinis é cada vez maior.
Não há artista nenhum de culto que
não queira lançar uma edição em vinil
do seu disco, e isso é fantástico.
Os formatos
são perfeitamente compatíveis.
Qualquer pessoa que tenha uma ideia
mesmo que não pareça a mais modernaça,
aquilo pode vingar.
Nós, em Portugal, independentemente
das simpatias que possamos ter,
há pessoas que se tornam virais,
fenómenos virais,
que se tornam populares,
e que interferem com a nossa vida
e que têm ideias que triunfam.
Eu pergunto: alguém,
aqui há 30 anos atrás,
algum de vocês podia prever que nós,
enquanto povo, enquanto comunidade,
íamos votar três vezes em Cavaco Silva
para primeiro-ministro?
(Risos)
E, não satisfeitos, votámos mais duas
para presidente da República.
Aconteceu.
(Aplausos)
E quem é que havia de dizer que nós,
enquanto comunidade,
íamos votar em António Costa
para primeiro-ministro?
Não votámos. Ok, não votámos.
Mas a questão não é essa.
A questão é a da dinâmica.
Aquela ideia que toda a gente pensava
que estava derrotada,
goste-se ou não se goste,
é a que está mais próxima de vir a ser
implementada enquanto programa de governo.
Ponto.
Eu não discuto se simpatizam ou não.
É-me completamente indiferente.
É como a Adele, não me faz diferença
que gostem ou não da Adele.
Peguei no exemplo da Adele
para mostrar
que o formato disco não acabou,
apesar de nos terem vendido essa ideia.
Qualquer ideia que nós tenhamos,
pode vir a ser uma ideia vencedora.
Eu hoje ao almoço estava a falar
com um amigo que vai falar
mais daqui a bocado,
sobre a questão da tecnologia,
e eu estava-lhe a dizer:
"Há tanta gente a trabalhar
em novas tecnologias."
Eu acho que esta obsessão com
a tecnologia pode ser castrador
para quem não tem um doutoramento
em Física Quântica ou coisa parecida.
Qualquer de nós pode ter uma ideia
que venha a ser uma ideia vencedora.
Se eu herdar um pomar,
um talão de um avô,
que tenha lá umas macieiras,
com a nova moda da agricultura biológica,
— a agricultura foi inventada
há mais de 10 mil anos —
eu posso querer triunfar a vender maçãs.
Eu não tenho de construir nada
de rigorosamente novo,
para conseguir fazer qualquer coisa
de novo no mundo.
Era esta a mensagem
que eu vos queria deixar.
A mim, aconteceu-me, de repente,
ser uma personagem de banda desenhada.
Não sei o que é que vocês
têm previsto para o vosso futuro.
Eu tenho-me divertido muito,
o único conselho que posso dar é:
Não deixem de se divertir
durante o processo.
Façam a tal coisa em que acreditem
porque, mesmo que o projeto
não venha a ser um sucesso,
se vocês se divertirem no processo,
nunca será um fracasso.
porque vão ser mais felizes graças
a uma ideia que tentaram implementar.
De facto, a única coisa que distingue
uma ideia que se pode concretizar
duma que fica na gaveta é aquele momento
em que nós perguntamos "What if...?"
"E se...?"
É só isso.
(Aplausos)
Obrigadíssimo.
E já agora...
Como ele está a chegar,
Feliz Natal para todos, está bem?
(Aplausos)